at a news conference at one of its
buildings in gaza
which was itself damaged during the
bombardment
the un briefed reporters the intensity
of the strikes were without
pause too many homes were lost and loved
ones are gone
many people told me they feel helpless
and even hopeless they have no control
over their lives
parents say they cannot reassure their
children that this won't happen again
the head of the un agency that looks
after palestinians
said that while humanitarian aid and
reconstruction funding
were now essential they were in
themselves
not enough it is not a replacement for
peace
or for the human rights of all the root
causes
of the conflict remain the occupation
the forced displacement of which we had
a strong reminder
in cherry lately the blockade and the
cycle
of violence all remain this
must be resolved next week all eyes will
be on the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken
who'll visit the region on wednesday
it's vitally important
that the palestinians feel hope
and have opportunity and can live in
security just as it is for israelis
and there should be equal measures and
in a democratic society
that is i think an obligation of the of
any government
so a somewhat different tone from
washington but what's most
important is what secretary blinken
didn't say he gave
no indication that he's going to try to
restart
active diplomacy leading to negotiations
between the israelis and palestinians
james bays al jazeera west jerusalem